dynamic html5
it feels like to me maybe you can
correct me like a beautiful
piece of design work it was uh it's not
often with web stuff
you have this breadth of just like oh
whoever did this
is did they fix it this just feels good
uh
is that what what are your thoughts
about html is the am i being too
romantic a little bit a little bit are
there flaws fundamental flaws to it that
i'm just not aware of
my you know my old friend hicks did a
great job he was a another
a renegade physics student uh he and he
was a
basically a qa guy at opera but he
obviously a
trained physics you know uh student and
uh someone who could write
a british or he he developed test suites
and he started thinking about them
more axiomatically now this is this can
be good because you can sort of
systematize in a way that makes a better
html
or you can get caught in the pragmatism
of saying well we have to handle these
edge cases so we're just going to have
sort of a
test matrix and if the matrix is large
it will not be beautiful by many
people's lights everyone likes to
minimize
along their preferred dimensions the
seven special forms in
scheme or whatever but but reality
is html needs uh to be big it's kind of
symbolic
it's a creative multi-paradigm and hixi
did a good job i would say with
a bunch of it other people came in in
the spirit of ian hickson to
do html5 work and they've carried on
that effort and it's a
so it's a mix of pragmatism de facto
standards from the past being sort of
combined or written down for the first
time and then rethought in a way that
has a simpler syntax like the fetch api
instead of xml http request
video too as well it ultimately it feels
like maybe you can correct me it feels
like
it was the nail in the coffin flash
steve jobs
saying no flash on the iphone in my
opinion was the actual stick to the
heart
but but well i'm not sure what trope you
want to use this flash was a zombie for
until just this year right or last year
i think last year was the end of flash
in
maine browsers um but jobs really did
the death blow
and uh yeah you're right we had to make
html5 competitive
i still don't think we got that
beautiful timeline
animation the timeline thing yeah you
like the time i mean me from uh
i you know i used to animate all kinds
of stuff inside flash plus there's a
programming element
yes it was a little bit i don't know if
you can
comment on that but to me it was a
little bit like go-to statement like
in a sense that it was a little bit too
chaotic
like it didn't that ocd part of me as a
programmer
wasn't satisfied by flash it feels like
there was bugs
that were introduced through the
animation process that i couldn't debug
easily yes
i heard that too i i didn't use it so
i'm doing the grasses greener thing here
yeah the thing about
i liked about the animation model was
that it was this immutable function of
time so you could
time warp and you could if you dodged
these bugs or worked carefully
you could really make it sing in ways
that i think still a little challenging
with
the web animation standards but or just
using raw canvas and webgl
um but there's so many tools now that
maybe it doesn't matter
and and yet we had to you know do video
we had to do
webgl and then evolve it we had to do
web audio um
but once we did all these things that
helped flash
uh die thanks to steve gubs we had
something that um people didn't realize
we had that vision that mark infusion
had this this graphics cable capable
to the metal portable runtime
you